this is a second run of the Singapore
design week and we have nearly 60 events
the whole idea of the Singapore design
week is to begin to bring international
designers to begin to speak with local
designers we have the dialogue with them
to celebrate design to promote design to
develop capabilities
there's a body of work of my life here
and it feels to me that Singapore has
that confidence now and my hope is that
I'll be coming back here for years to
come always enjoy kind of having
discussions with Singapore architects
and designers and seeing what you're
doing and subsea what we're doing over
in the UK
with consumer events like Singapore or
our key trade shows such as the
International Furniture Fair Singapore
or Maison the object Asia there's
something for everyone whether you're a
student in design whether your design
enthusiast or whether you're actually in
the business of furniture production or
design thing is various I think to be
part of asian star showcase there's a
lot of people from different parts of
the region most importantly all of them
actually young and new designers where I
think we could get together and know
each other better so that we can grow as
a community not just in the country but
in the region itself over all ffs is a
very good exhibition and it's very
inspiring as well
we have curated a very very interesting
combination of retail of design of
fashion of dining there's so much
happening in Singapore and for everyone
that comes for Singapore design me I
encourage you to look around and enjoy
the city as well